prisma an open source tool that makes it
fun and safe to work with your database
the relational database is ancient
technology that has stood the test of
time but writing sql code is not an
ideal abstraction for modern app
development it provides too much low
level control and you'll probably blow
your foot off writing it to address this
concern orms like sqlize implement
object relational mapping to express
data with object oriented code like
javascript classes prisma is also an orm
that addresses similar problems but
instead it has its own declarative
schema definition language you write a
schema to express your data and
relationships in a human readable way or
the schema can be automatically inferred
from any existing database prisma then
converts the schema into type
definitions allowing you to perform
typesafe crud operations with your own
database models which means you get ide
autocompletion tailored to your own
custom schema in addition it handles
migrations as your data structure
evolves and if you want to visualize
your data prisma studio allows you to
view and manage all of your tables and
rows in the browser to get started
you'll need a relational database like
mysql or postgres although mongodb is
supported as well from a nodejs project
run npx prisma init this creates a env
file where you can add your database url
and a prisma directory to define the
schema if the existing database already
has data we can run prismadb pool to
introspect it and automatically generate
the schema from it notice how each table
is represented with the model keyword
then inside the braces we have column
names and their data types as well as
optional constraints like for example we
might use relation to create a foreign
key constraint between a weapon and a
human and we can also index the weapon
id while we're at it the beauty of this
is that the code is significantly more
concise than what you would write
otherwise in raw sql now if we decide to
modify our schema like add an extra
timestamp column we'll also need to
modify the database structure which can
be handled automatically with the prisma
migrate command now to interact with the
database on the server we tell prisma to
generate the client library import the
client into a javascript file and notice
how it auto-completes the models in the
schema if you do something wrong you'll
know about it right away now find all
the humans with the find menu method to
filter the results we can add a where
clause as a plain javascript object and
if we want to join a related table we
can do that by adding the include object
prisma already knows how to run the
complicated sql code under the hood and
returns the data as an array of
javascript objects ready to use in your
application this has been prisma in 100
seconds if you want to see more short
videos like this hit the like button and
subscribe and let me know if you want to
see a full prisma tutorial in the
comments thanks for watching and i will
see you in the next one